i came over here in the morning a few
days ago
and i saw courtney and scott asleep
together on the couch
you're lying kourtney kardashian and her
ex
scott disick got the rumor mill turning
thanks to a casual mid-morning nap
and turns out court's famous sisters
want them to give their relationship
another go do we think they're like
hooking up again i just want them to try
in a clip from the upcoming 20th and
final season of keeping up with the
kardashians
kim kardashian tells khloe kardashian
and kendall jenner that
she caught the exes having a snooze sesh
together what kind of together though no
they were like separate they weren't
like spooning on the couch or anything
but like he was here and she was here
they weren't far away though
they were close i mean pete was with me
last night court asked if i would
have a sleepover with pete because she's
been asking for so long
so who was here because just courtney
and scott oh my god
and they weren't on like opposite ends
yeah so that led the sisters to wonder
what we're all wondering do we think
they're like hooking up again i just
want them to try
i don't know maybe i mean scott's single
right now
if he's fully moves on like has a baby
does that she's going to freak out like
what's the harm in trying the worst that
will happen is they're like you know
what
we don't vibe with this i agree but
they're also too pretty to try
i think they're afraid that they're
going to like mess up their good
co-parenting
of course scott and court share three
kiddos together
eleven-year-old mason eight-year-old
penelope and
six-year-old reign and the two have
managed to stay close and co-parent
ever since their high profile breakup in
2015.
i mean i think we've been through so
much in so many things and to hear her
be proud of me means you know a ton to
me they're so good at the co-parenting
thing
that court's sister chloe gave them mad
props during
a chat with e.t in 2019. i'm so proud of
them and i'm so proud of them promoting
that it's a beautiful thing to get along
with each other and for your kids to see
that and while kim chloe and kendall are
rooting for a reconciliation
the 37 year old reality star rang in the
new year in mexico with 19 year old
model amelia hamlin
a source recently told e.t that scott is
still dating amelia
and having fun with her abcd
i have to go what the heck is abcdefg
mean
and in december e.t source said court
isn't bothered by scott's new
relationship
she knows scott better than anybody and
she is supportive
as for the push founder well she has a
new romance too
with blink 182 drummer travis barker
i'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens
according to a source scott is
supportive of it and
wants courtney to be happy at the end of
the day i mean you just want to be happy
you want to be content you want to be
comfortable we'll just have to tune
in to see how it all unfolds on the
final season of keeping up with the
kardashians
when it premieres march 18th on e